There are about a million things you can do
wrong when starting up Pokemon Sun and Moon,
so we've taken it upon ourselves to give you
some tips on what not to do while adventuring
in Alola. Here's are some things to avoid
in Pokemon Sun and Moon.
Don't restart for shiny Pokemon
Sure, it's tempting to restart your game to
try and get a shiny starter Pokemon, but keep
in mind that getting one to spawn is a 1-in-4,000
chance.
“Hahaha...oh my God, I got it. I’m still
shaking.”
And since you have to endure three minutes
of dialogue every time you restart, your time
is probably better spent progressing the game
so you can breed your own shiny Pokemon instead.
“OH MY GOD! SHINY ROWLET! SHINY ROWLET!
OH MY GOD! WE GOT IT! WE GOT IT!”
Don't avoid Trainer battles
When a nearby Trainer is looking to brawl,
the screen dims, making it easy to avoid the
fights if you want to. But you shouldn't skip
them: not only will your Pokemon get much-needed
experience, but you'll also build up a good
amount of cash and snag a few items here and
there. Plus, it's a good idea to clear the
area so if you need to backtrack you won't
have these Trainers attacking you all the
time.
Don't stick with the same team
It's tempting to keep your original six Pokemon,
especially since they might be your strongest
and highest level. But mixing and matching
your team isn't just part of the fun — it
allows you to switch strategies to overcome
specific enemies. And since you can get the
E. X. P. Share item early on in the game,
it's relatively easy to bring a new, lower-level
Pokemon up to speed with the rest of your
team after a few battles, since it'll get
half the experience your active Pokemon earns.
Don't over-level your Pokemon
It may sound weird, but it's possible your
Pokemon could become more powerful than you.
Yup, it's true: if you over-level your Pokemon,
they may stop listening to your orders. Instead,
level your team to the proper levels and then
complete the Grand Trials that reward you
with stamps on your Trainer Passport that
allows higher-level Pokemon to follow your
commands.
Don't blow your cash on clothing
One of the coolest features in Pokemon Sun
and Moon is the ability to customize your
character's appearance, from the clothes they
wear to the hairstyles they rock. But while
it's tempting to bling yourself out, make
sure you save enough money for things that
actually affect gameplay, like Pokeballs,
Revives, Super Potions, and maybe the occasional
Escape Rope or two. Don't worry, by the end
of the game you'll have enough cash to do
whatever you want.
Don't neglect your Ride Pokemon
Your Ride Pager is there for a reason, so
don't walk around like a rube when you can
be charging your way through areas in half
the time with your Tauros. As you continue
the story, you'll get access to more Ride
Pokemon with different abilities, some of
which can even net you more items, like the
Stoutland and its Search skill that can sniff
out hidden objects. It's easy to forget that
you have these Ride Pokemon at your service
until an obstacle is in your way, but be sure
to use them and to use them often, especially
because they can get you to hidden areas with
cool items to collect.
Don't forget to save
This seems like a no-brainer, but plenty of
people forget to save their games every so
often. This, of course, can result in losing
precious progress, either in the story or
in training up Pokemon. Thankfully, the game
saves after you trade Pokemon with someone,
so you don't have to worry about losing a
new friend, but there could be worse scenarios.
Given that the game is on a portable console,
you're always in danger of losing battery
life in the middle of an important battle
or Trial, so save often. Because you know
how you'll feel if you don't.
Don't neglect Pokemon Refresh
Want to build up your Pokemon's affection
and bond with them? Well, that's what Pokemon
Refresh is for. Every so often, you'll see
a "Care" option on the touchscreen of your
device after a battle. Pressing "Y" will lead
you to the Pokemon Refresh screen and task
you with either cleaning up your Pokemon or
getting rid of their status ailments, like
paralysis or poison.
Not only that, but you can feed them Poke
Beans and pet them to raise their affection
towards you. Once you max out their affection,
they'll be able to do cool things in battle
like dodge attacks in response to your "shouts,"
shake off status effects, and even wish for
your praise after they land critical hits.
It pays to bond with your Pokemon.
Don't randomly overwrite moves
Your Pokemon's move list is what gives it
flavor in battle and can be crucial to winning
matches, especially if you're a competitive
player. With that said, don't just keep deleting
old moves every time your Pokemon levels up
and tries to learn a new skill. The new skills
might seem cool, but it's possible the old
skill is actually better. Luckily, there are
sites to help you study up to see which skills
are best for you and your Pokemon.
Don't ignore the hidden Zygarde cells
If you notice some swirling green or pink
lights anywhere in the world, you should go
up to them and investigate. These are Zygarde
Cells and Cores, which make up the Pokemon
called, well, Zygarde. It's easy to overlook
them, but it's a good idea to collect as many
of these as you go so that you can create
the 10 percent and 50 percent Forms, eventually
collecting 100/100 elements to create the
100 percent Form. It might take some time,
but if you've ever wanted a Pokemon that kind
of looks like a Transformer, here's your chance.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!